I was wrong.
I was foolish.
I don't get to play by different rules.
The same boundaries that apply to everyone apply to me.
I brought this shame on myself.
I hurt my wife, my kids,...
...my mother, my wife's family,...
...my friends, my foundation...
...and kids all around the world who admired me.
I've had a lot of time to think about what I've done.
My failures have made me look at myself...
...in a way I never wanted to before.
It's now up to me to make amends...
...and that starts by never repeating the mistakes I've made.
It's up to me to start living a life of integrity.
I once heard and I believe it's true,...
...it's not what you achieve in life that matters,...
...it's what you overcome.
Achievements on the golf course are only part of setting an example.
Character and decency are what really count.